as an eu citizen you have the right to
live work or study in any eu country
iceland norway or liechtenstein
sometimes though public authorities
might not respect your eu rights
for instance if you're a doctor
hairdresser or architect and you want to
work in another eu country the
authorities there might tell you that
you're not fully qualified to work there
or perhaps you're an eu national working
in another eu country and you're not
getting child benefits for your family
back home
or perhaps you've just moved to another
eu country and your brazilian wife is
having problems getting residence papers
anything like this happens to you
solvit is a quick free service that can
help all you have to do is go to the
solvit website and in your own language
submit your case
the national solveit centers concerned
will handle your case
once your problem is solved you can
enjoy your rights in the eu
to learn more visit our website
brought to you by solvit